[Music]
in petty arrests news i'm danny
submitted by my body is ready oh oh
horny bastards the lappa de or LAPD is
under fire over a video of a cop
forcibly dragging a woman off the train
because she had her feet on the seats
thinks it clearly in asia because you
cannot do that you just said to lap it
up exactly that doesn't sound very real
because her feet were on the seat well
like that's like that why would a cop
drag you out cuz your foots on oh I know
why why ya know because he thought she
was fine he wanted to get the digits she
was like hmm I had to do this he's like
oh really [ __ ] I didn't even watch
number anyway what your seat [ __ ] it on
the fiancée Peter let's see the cop
doesn't speak English very well
you want to peed on a seat you sound
like you're auctioning something off and
spinner to see Peter to see like Mexican
or something like that that's what you
gonna take her [ __ ] me but the real
question is how smelly were her feet
because I should spank I would
understand oh I feel like she was just
bratty from what I saw in the video you
saw the video I saw the video I wanna
see the video alright so it turns out
that this girl it seems like this is how
she had her foot on the oh no I hope lip
all the way no it wasn't even on another
seat it was just on her own seat that's
what it seems like that's what I
understood for you though you would get
your [ __ ] leg chopped off at your
kneecap for doing that [ __ ] what part in
Asia have you know have you seen Chinese
people the way they eat just I'm talking
about the civilized part okay no you
can't you can't do that out in public
like on a transition you can't do that
okay you could do it in a restaurant if
your
ghetto I mean there's like regular
Chinese people and then there's the ones
that come out here those ones you gotta
have both knees up sometimes that's how
they poo that's how me poop they squat
yeah that's how they drop flying out his
[ __ ] mouth disgusting dude mm-hmm
yeah so apparently this cop saw her do
that and he went up to her and said like
hey take your foot down and she
apparently declined to do that and so
that's when he just went crazy he was
just like you got to go up the tree
right now and then he starts like
pulling her up and then I'm just gonna
show you the video
yeah I just chose to pity
that's a nice hoodie I could touch your
mom she looks like a child should they
please officer please please officer
please officer please please stop doing
this officer please don't do this
what to do officers really matter yes
it's really not a big deal it was a
chair
it was just 31 FP 140 giving it back at
the location I'm at the West Lake
MacArthur Park
I'm 18 give me some space guys well that
sucks
of course I thought he was cuffing her
it look like he's stalking Wow
all that happened and then there's other
witness she got involved and she was the
one that said like are you [ __ ]
kidding me in the background
so she just was very vocal in this whole
ordeal here to the point where she also
got arrested and like she was like
spitting at a cop too
but she was just like are you Anna this
is a real abusive pet of your power
she wasn't blocking anyone else from
sitting down you're really gonna take
her to jail for putting her foot on the
bus are you kidding me that's what
someone said yeah I thought they're both
pretty dumb because one with hers I kind
of choose your battles you know like no
I'm not gonna put my foot down like mmm
kind of not a big deal but then also
he's [ __ ] going crazy both made in a
big deal and they both made a big deal
it's dumb who's the guy that was
recording her boyfriend or something
I just someone that was there there are
several people recording but not one I
guess made it to the yeah
thank goodness for cell phones and video
for real these people need to get
checked I don't even know what cuz like
we're not if I was younger I would have
been like man [ __ ] the cops that's
[ __ ] wrong but now that I'm older and
I see how disorderly our society is and
it's kind of like well he's really not
wrong to tell you to put your foot down
like if an older woman came up to me and
she was like you know you should
probably sit up straight I think I'd be
like oh yeah you're right I am I am kind
of dirtying this seat with my [ __ ]
dirty shoes and then other people are
gonna use that you're like you know I
mean it's like oh [ __ ] I shouldn't be
doing that you're right thank you but
there's also like the whole history with
the police and and everyone's like well
I'm not gonna listen to you because it's
not a legal [ __ ] I just like
inherently when you look at the big
picture what he did was very I mean you
can't really like justify that at the
same time but it's also excessive it's
very excessive and it's just like at the
same time though like I always look at
the other side where it's like you
wouldn't have to get I mean it you know
what it means like I don't know maybe
it's cuz I'm lazy and I don't want to
just I don't want to get you know I mean
so there's I put your [ __ ] foot down
I'm gonna throw you off the strange yeah
I mean it's not like the officer was
wrong either like fully wrong because of
the fact that it is in the code of
conduct for the metro that placing
feeder shoes on seats are furnishing is
prohibited disorderly conduct which may
be penalized with a warning and/or
ejection from the Train oh you would
within his falling the rules its choose
your battles kind of thing because if it
was if it was me I would rather fight
for my right for something better
exactly like I paid to be on this train
but it's a but still you're not you
don't own it like if it was my friends
and I was telling them like yeah I told
the cop no I'm going to protect that
homeless lady okay that's one thing but
no I stood my ground I put my feet on
the chair and it doesn't even work
because apparently is you're not
supposed to do that yeah so he was with
completely within his rights yeah and
other people didn't even know that
either
I don't really think he was that
aggressive it's just because a size
difference yeah but if if he was doing
that to another guy his size I think
I've already split all you should have
just not put his foot up you know what
was expressed is excessive is when that
one cop went into the the classroom and
body slammed that little girl yeah sure
- it was [ __ ] crazy that was just
like he's kind of dragging her out
that's excessive but I mean he could
have used his brain and talked to her
yeah and maneuvered it through you know
words versus like that but that girl was
a little brat - yeah
even if yeah I feel like if you weren't
just talking she make no I paid to be
here
like I don't think it would have worked
she also looked like unit dude and they
don't run on logic yeah that's true an
arm swing those earrings girl swing
those earrings yeah rev up girl ran up
from mom he's always gonna get it when
he gets home even know why he tries to
act all brave watch our vlogs you could
see who wears the pants when I was
around 18 I would have done the same
[ __ ] I would have I would have stood up
for my rights cuz you know you don't
yeah you're 18 and you're like you're
taught that oh you know Rosa Parks stood
up for her rights she might be seeing
this as an example of like I'm I'm a I'm
a [ __ ] warrior like I'm gonna almost
stand up against injustice you know like
that's what she's probably thinking yeah
cuz I can from her perspective she's
saying I'm not doing anything wrong I'm
not preventing anyone else from sitting
around me like all I'm doing is putting
my foot on the seat what's the big deal
a little bit yeah I mean I mean in that
situation or like who really reads the
Code of Conduct when using public
transportation like I wouldn't know so
she probably sees everyone else doing it
so she probably took it as why is this
fool picking on me like always like he
probably picked on my family member he's
probably picked on my friends now he's
picking on me because of this she
probably thought like [ __ ] that like I'm
not gonna get picked on today true like
on the other side like who really
enforces [ __ ] like that you know I mean
for the amount of cops that we have per
like square footage in LA like I felt
like this cop could be doing something
much better for for the city than to
kick out 18 year old on yeah that's why
that second woman that got involved her
name is Selena she's she was saying that
like what you have nothing better to do
are you trying to meet your quota quota
quota you're what if all the chairs had
the same Skechers imprint and he was
like ah he's 100 on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're the infamous sketcher stepper our
metro kind of sucks though like I've
rode the train once or twice I had a
friend that always used it and then he
so broke Doby times when guy like back
then when there wasn't a cop on the
train or something a guy would just
start smoking like crack right in front
of ya like a bum would just stole away
walk inside and then like start taking a
dump in the middle of the Train and like
why is that good change then yeah yeah
just manhandle it looks like manhandling
this eighteen year old girl so that's
what just I think it is it's it's just
too much for what what it is like you
should have just been more of a mentor
and told her like you know
everyone shares that area and you're
putting your foot there like think about
I mean there might be more like passive
ways like let's see if she was giving
him crazy attitude and he wants to eject
her maybe write her a citation or
something yeah but I think like the
actual physical act I think it was just
two egos going at it
yep at that point it wasn't really to
teach anyone yeah he was pulling her
saying grab your stuff she's like I can
get myself a beer pulling me up so yeah
it was just like you're not there
talking to me yeah
grab your stuff when you hold on to this
oh yeah you're not a superhero what the
[ __ ]
[Music]